[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Marvel phase four video
for all the movie changes that Disney
just announced that's right all the
Marvel movies from Marvel phase four are
now coming out completely different
times they've changed their entire
schedule so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon gift card giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which Marvel
phase four movie you're most excited
about so we'll just do this top ten
style blowing through all the movies
starting with number ten if you didn't
see the news this morning Marvel
announced a new release date for Black
Widow but here's the catch not only are
they moving it to later this year
they're also bumping every single Marvel
phase four movie in the process the
reason they would do something like this
is to make sure that the Marvel timeline
in the way they tell stories in an
interconnected way the overarching
infinity saga of it all makes sense the
Black Widow movie is supposed to set up
some of that big story is the first real
official Marvel phase four movie even
though technically spider-man far from
home takes place after avengers endgame
so some of these movie changes also
include the Marvel phase 5 movies I just
did a video about how Sony is doing the
same thing with the Morbius and venom 2
movies because Morbius is supposed to
set up all this sinister six and
spider-man stuff we saw those Easter
eggs in the trailer but Sony just
delayed the movie now it's not coming
out till after venom 2 so obviously
they're gonna have to change a couple
things about the way they do those
Easter eggs so that their timeline makes
sense for Tom Holland crossover
eventually in all the sinister six stuff
Marvel is a little bit better about
weaving that story together so I don't
think they're gonna have too many
problems but the good news in all this
is that they have not delayed any of the
Disney Plus Avengers spin-off series so
like Falcon and Winter Soldier is still
coming out at the end of the summer
Wanda vision is still coming out in
December so even though some of that
story will pick up where Black Widow
leaves off in the Black Widow
post-credit scene whatever it is that
they're actually doing with all the
Thunderbolt Ross Thunderbolts weapon
plus super soldiers stuff it's not going
to completely break their timeline by
releasing Black Widow after Falcon and
Winter Soldier don't worry I'll be doing
episode videos and Easter eggs for all
the Disney Plus stuff so when
stuff starts coming I'll explain how
it's connected to the movie stuff
number eight since Black Widow took the
Eternals release date in November
Eternals is now taking the shang-chi in
the legend of the ten rings release date
February next year the Eternals movie is
jumping all over the MCU timeline some
will take place tens of thousands of
years ago and explained how the
Celestials were created then they
created the Eternals in how the Eternals
influenced the rise of civilization to
present-day some of the movie will take
place after avengers endgame in
present-day MCU probably also after
spider-man far from home in the timeline
I've already done a couple videos about
the movie but if you're a big fan of the
cosmic Marvel storytelling it's gonna
get really cosmic 7 because eternals
took shane cheese release dates ain't
she is now bumping dr. strange - there
been a lot of rumors that shang-chi is
actually gonna take place in that five
year gap between Avengers infinity war
after Thanos snapped the universe but
before avengers endgame if that rumor
winds up being true i think the logic
and doing it that way just so that in
present-day MCU 2023 when shang-chi
shows up with all these other heroes
he's already become full comic book
shang-chi the movie's supposed to be
something akin to Marvel's version of
Bruce Lee's Enter the Dragon great
martial arts film with a big tournament
component and of course the real
Mandarin of the MCU and speaking of
Enter the Dragon there's also a rumor
that sing Fang Foom the actual MCU
dragon will show up during the movie 6
Doctor Strange 2 is now coming out in
November 2021 taking Thor force original
date I've already done a couple videos
about Doctor Strange - and what's going
on during the movie Scarlet Witch in
Wanda vision causes some quote-unquote
trouble with reality because of her
Chaos magic she teams up with Doctor
Strange to fight another multiverse
villian most likely to be nightmare from
the nightmare dimension but not
confirmed yet and even better that movie
is now being directed by Sam Raimi of
spider-man Fame Marvel revealed that
because it's gonna be a big multiverse
movie we'll get to see alternate
versions of MCU heroes teased maybe
we'll get to see them do the iron mage
Doctor Strange which was a deleted scene
from Avengers infinity war where Doctor
Strange becomes Iron Man there have also
been a lot of rumors about it featuring
other mutants and x-men based character
teasers but I'm not
expecting a ton of x-men to show up
during that number five since Doctor
Strange 2 took Thor fours release date
Thor 4 is now coming out February 2022
so we're starting to eat into the Marvel
phase 5 timeline Marvel had a bunch of
untitled movie release dates that it
created for Marvel phase 5 movies so
Thor 4 is still technically meant to be
the last big Marvel phase 4 movie but
it's now just eating into when the
Marvel phase 5 movies were starting to
come out if you haven't been watching
his Instagram Chris Hemsworth has been
spending all this time being trapped in
his home getting super ripped again to
play swole Thor so even though they'll
probably make some thick Thor jokes at
the beginning of the movie he's not
gonna be thick Thor anymore during Thor
for our IP Star Wars Bowflex most of the
movies inspired by the Mighty Thor comic
book story Christian Bale was confirmed
as their main villain by Tessa Thompson
a little while ago we don't know exactly
who he's playing his characters just
described as an intergalactic villain
but major theories are gore the god
butcher in beta ray bill is also
supposed to be featured during the movie
I'll do more Thor for videos when we get
some more information about what's going
on during the actual plot but number 4
black panther 2 has not changed it's
still coming out May 20-22
it's supposed to be the first major
Marvel phase 5 movie for a couple
reasons mostly because around this time
they're gonna start integrating the Fox
x-men mutant characters in a much bigger
way there's all kinds of rumors about
who the villains are going to be there's
rumors about Namor being the main
villain even Doctor Doom of the
Fantastic Four either way it's gonna be
awesome they're gonna introduce a bunch
of really cool big stuff
number 3 next big movie is Captain
Marvel 2 coming out July 2022 it'll take
place in present-day MCU not the past
like the first movie they'll follow up
on Nick Fury's sword Space Station from
the Captain Marvel Comics the sword
characters will also show up during one
division 2 but even though she's
probably the most connected character to
all this Nick Fury sword Space Station
stuff that will be featured throughout
the MCU movies they won't wait two or
three years to go back to that space
station there's lots of rumors about it
featuring x-men characters but Marvel
has already confirmed that Miss Marvel
will be in the movie
so the Miss Marvel of Disney Plus series
will be released
sometime before Captain Marvel two comes
out we don't know exactly when she's
gonna be younger like she is in the
comics around the same age as Tom
Hollands spider-man but they haven't
cast an actress for her yet there is a
mystery Marvel movie coming out October
2022 we don't know exactly what it is
but the big rumor is that it will be
Deadpool 3 right now it's currently
believed that Ant Man 3 is supposed to
come out February 2023 we don't know
what the plot of that will be other than
they'll continue to explore the quantum
realm and continue the story of the
quantum city that they teased during Ant
Man and the wasp number 2 Marvel's new
Fantastic Four movie is rumored to be
coming out May 2023 Kevin Feige has
implied that when they introduce all the
new x-men and Fantastic Four characters
they'll do it in very different ways
that the Fox movies did it my
understanding is that just means that
they're gonna do it spider-man Civil War
style where Reed Richards and the other
Fantastic Four characters show up in
other people's movies then they do the
big team-up Fantastic Four solo movie in
the same treatment for the Marvel x-men
movie x-men characters showing up in
other people's films then they do the
big x-men team up movie and because the
new Fantastic Four characters and other
new x-men characters will cross over
with Avengers 5 and the other Avengers
movies in present day it implies that
there so the movies will also at least
be partially set in present-day in
number one spider-man 4 is coming out
July 2023 since it's number 4 were Tom
Holland if they're gonna keep using home
in the title I'll tentatively call this
spider-man home run
Sony Marvel have revealed that they've
been setting up a sinister six movie
since they did spider-man homecoming
also using the Morbius movie because we
saw that trailer with sinister six
characters venom 2 and all the
spider-man spin-offs that Sony is doing
so right now spider-man 4 seems like
it's going to be there full blown
spider-man vs. the sinister six movie
and if it wasn't clear spider-man 3 is
still coming out July 2021 the reason
why it's not on this Marvel phase 4
schedule is because technically Sony is
releasing the movie Marvel's just making
it this is mostly meant to be about
Marvel's plans for their release
schedule there'll be a lot of spider-man
venom crossovers on the Sony side like
venom 3 a maximum carnage movie other
big spider-man's
but those will be Sony's official
schedule so they'll publish that
sometime in the next couple of months -
and remember even though Marvel just
delayed all their movies that are coming
up they did not delay the Disney Plus
series
personally I would have rather they just
released Black Widow in July so they
didn't have to move every single Marvel
phase four movie but I think this is
Marvel just hedging their bets assuming
that the virus delays will affect the
production on the other movies that are
coming up - if you have any of the big
questions about what's coming up or what
Marvel just announced just leave them on
the video and I'll try to add it to my
future videos but there'll be a bunch of
big Marvel stuff happening soon and
supposedly Sony will be releasing the
venom 2 trailer really soon as well
because they have not changed the
release date of venom to everyone click
here for my brand new marvel x-men
teaser from Disney Plus recently and
click here for the new venom 2 teaser
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight